Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday flap ea
and April 17th, 2017 what's going on?
How are you? Happy Patriot's
day, everybody. Um,
I believe that only move towards my
voice right now. I believe that uh,
Massachusetts is Kinda the only place
that takes Patriot's day off kind of,
sort of, you know, they had
the Boston Marathon, right?
They usually play a red sox game during
the day for everybody doesn't want to
fucking run around and watch a bunch
of skinny people running down the damn
streets shitting themselves
on handbrake hill.
Every year is somebody shits
themselves in that race.
You know that anytime there's a marathon,
there's people that push themselves so
hard that they literally shit themselves.
It's the fucking running up the
hill. You know, those runners,
they were those little fucking
nylon shorts and stuff.
So there's nowhere for it to go.
And these maniacs say, just stay,
just keep running with shit going
down the back of their legs.
Like one of those fucking
horses that carries, you know,
drags the newlyweds around the park.
You know, but even them, you know,
they put the tail up, they
fucking shoot it out. Oh,
he's going in early with the shit jokes.
Everybody says what it's gonna be.
Is it literally going to
be who should show? Um,
yeah, so whatever happy
page you'd stayed everybody.
I don't even know what
Patriot's day is. You know,
I don't think it's about the football
team because it's not football season is
just that when we raise the banner
Patriot state, let's look it up. Shall We?
People Patriots Day a
Hashtag. What the fuck is it?
Why does it automatically
go to fucking Wikipedia?
Even though I would've gone here. All
right. Then there's this Patriot Day,
a film starring mark, Mark Walberg.
That's not what I was looking for.
Cock suckers. I just don't
understand. I had, oh my God,
I had the worst day with my
fucking phone. Like yesterday.
I tried to update it.
Um,
you know,
and then it comes back on and then you
need all your fucking passwords and no
matter how much I type them in,
the way they're supposed to be,
it doesn't recognize it.
Then it shuts down my phone.
Then it's going la balls,
your guten tag and like 50 different
fucking languages and I can't, I can't.
I came. So if I had not, I
haven't meditated in a month,
I'm not going to lie to you, but I, I,
if I hadn't meditated so much in
the beginning part of the year,
I would've broke my phone
in half. I grabbed it,
I turned it sideways and I fucking
started. I started to do it.
I started the fucking
break it and I stopped.
I did throw it at the couch into the
cushions and I also did throw my laptop
into the, they were all into the cushions,
not overly hot. You know, it's funny,
when I lift up the laptop,
I felt the pain of my rotator cuff
so I could only throw it so hard.
It was really pathetic. It was
a pathetic display of anger. Uh,
okay.
So, you know, I dunno, my phone
still fucking with me. You know,
I'm trying to go into the God damn apple
store here and they won't let me do it.
I don't understand these,
you know, apple is,
everybody fucking loves
his got company. You know.
Can somebody please fucking explain to
me why they're so hostile when it comes
to any sort of customer support.
Is there a fucking reason?
There's not a phone number. I can't
talk to anybody. They're like, fuck you.
Here's our product that
doesn't work. Go Fuck Yourself.
We're not responsible for anything.
You don't know what we look like.
You don't know where we are.
Don't even talk to me about those fucking
apple stores with the people walking
around with the genius t shirts.
Give me a fucking break. Oh,
that sounds says cause somebody just came
into my house. I hear it all the time.
So I mean it doesn't mean
shit to me. Um, anyways.
[inaudible] that was like
an anger meter. You know,
as I was getting up higher would ring
and they would let me know to come back
down again. You know,
like an idiot light on some car that
your engine is overheating anyways.
Fuck those apple stores too.
All right, those that did that,
it's all bullshit. You're talking
to low level people in the,
in the company. Nobody who's fucking
designing these goddamn things.
It ended up being fucked up
is working at that store.
Okay?
We give him that stupid fucking shirt
that says genius usted se [inaudible]
um, and then what do
they got to deal with?
Fucking balding hot heads like me
who come walking in going like, dude,
where the fuck did all my music go?
Where did you put it on the cloud?
I don't want you to have my stuff.
Fine. I don't, you know, I should
have never stopped getting cds.
All I know is everything's
fucked up. Okay?
And so now I'm signing into shit on my
laptop. My phone's talking to me going,
hey, somebody signing in on another
device and there's no place for me to say,
yeah, I know it's me. And then
the laptop soon the same thing.
[inaudible] like it's like David Lee
Roth and Eddie van Halen. It's like,
you guys, you were great together.
We had the band and now you're fucking
breaking up and you're talking shit about
each other and don't even talk to me about
those fucking numbers I'm supposed to
punch in. Cause I did that
too. I went into my settings,
I fuck stupid. Uh, whatever.
Clicked on my name,
went into passwords type the fucking
number that they just sent me into the
thing and they said they didn't
recognize it and then they freeze up.
My phone frees up my phone. Like I'm
working in the Pentagon or something.
It comes from fucking general.
I'm just some jerk off who wants to
listen to some fucking hair metal from the
80s KKR, you know, while I get on a
treadmill, it's all I'm trying to do here.
You know what it is. It's
fucking, it's incestuous.
Yeah.
You know how really rich people want
to keep the money in their family,
you know, so they just sort of,
they sort of breed with the same five
families I've talked to you this before.
So it's why, you know, you
look at the, it's like they're,
they're good looking from the forehead
down to like the mouth area and then they
smile and it's Whoa. You know,
starts looking like they should
be playing a fucking banjo.
Okay.
You know? So it's the same thing
with technology. Technology.
It used to be a radio
was radio over there.
It's my stereo dad over there
is the dishwasher, right?
Slash. Maid. I'm sorry.
She's thinking about the
time I was talking about.
And then you had your walk wins, right?
Then the walk when also had a fucking
radio and a phone was a phone and now
they've all fought. They've all
just been gang banging. Right?
This big fucking calendula.
Fucking fisting technological,
I dunno what they're all
the same goddamn thing now.
Everything, everything is just on
those fucking things. And I don't know,
it's ridiculous. So what I ended up
doing as I, after I started to like,
it was weird.
Like I had the strength signals sent
from all the way to like my risks.
I didn't let it get to my hands. I felt
the anger go all, it's like the hulk,
right? The fucking my arms turn green
all the way down to my wrist and I just,
I stopped myself from breaking in
and half, but I have to, Oh God,
that would've been such a
great feeling to just snap.
It has to be youtube videos of people
snapping it. Fucking phones in half. Um,
what I did was I just
said, fuck that phone,
fuck the laptop and I hit a drum lesson
and I got in my truck and I just fucking
drove over any, I can
admit, you know what?
It was kind of fucking nice
not having a phone, you know,
I wasn't looking at text
messages, dwell driving.
I wasn't doing any of that type of shit.
Trying to fucking scroll in the next
God damn song. None of that shit.
I just was, I dunno, driving a car,
like I used to talking to myself and um,
and I came back calm down.
I tried it again and about, I
don't know, maybe the 17th attempt.
I got it to work again and uh,
I just got it as, you know,
as great as these are and my ability to
communicate with you guys and everything
like that. You know, I,
I still would've been
alright without these things.
I could have made it the old fashioned
way is a comedian where you just keep
doing the clubs and doing the clubs than
I do with guest spot on the Hollywood
squares right next to
Paul Lynde. You know,
maybe do a fucking tonight show
and I just keep building up.
I could've made it that way. I
didn't need all of this shit.
All this shit that these
fucking Yolo Deuces, you know,
selfies and then the, the picture you
take that it takes sort of a video,
but it's a picture, but
it's also a video, you know,
these flying squirrel
suits, I mean, I don't know.
What is it you just to do shit that other
people didn't do? Is that what
it is? I don't fucking know.
You know, back in the day, you
know what it was back in the day,
you fucking did the clubs until you built
up enough of the following on your own
that you headlined clubs and then maybe
you got an hour special then you know
now if you're a middle act, you
need an hour special to headline.
Like the whole thing is to, I
just feel like this old man like,
okay,
what's the deal? But man, everything.
Alright patriots day, everybody.
Um, patriots day. Where is it?
Patriot stay in Massachusetts,
in Wisconsin and Patriot stay in
Maine is an official state holiday
commemorating the anniversary of the
battles of Lexington and Concord.
Well, what the fuck does Maine in
Wisconsin have to do with that?
The first battles of the American
revolution or does is main in Wisconsin,
the only other two fucking
states that respect our holiday.
The holiday was originally
celebrated on April 19th.
The actual anniversary of the battles
fought in 1775 since 1969 it's been
observed on the third Monday in April
in Massachusetts and in May. Doe,
let's get a three day
weekend out of it, you know,
fuck the 19th just make
sure it's on Monday.
It's also the first day of a vacation
week for public schools in both states,
in both states and a school holiday
for many low local colleges and
universities, both public and private.
The day is a public school
observance stay in Wisconsin.
Florida law also encourages
people to celebrate it.
Like those fucking people needed an
encouragement to celebrate. Anything else
you fucking celebrating? Like
everyday's Patriot's day.
Fucking meth day. Um, though it is
not treated as a public holiday.
Okay.
Obs, observances in reenactments
of battles occur occur.
I remember going to one
of those when I was a kid.
I thought those people were coolest shit,
shooting the guns and pretending
to die and all that stuff.
I thought it was awesome. Then I got older
and I was like, Hey, are you meeting?
If that's what he's into. All
right. The Boston Marathon.
He's run on Patriot's day
every fucking year. Therefore,
sometimes the holiday is
referred to as marathon.
Monday at the Boston red sox had been
sketched and had been scheduled to play at
home and Family Park and patriots day
every year since 1959 the games have
postpone to, to weather in 59, 61 65,
67 and 84 do I need all of this? All
right. We got it. Okay. We got it.
So that's what it is.
It's commemorating the first battles of
the American revolutions in a Lexington
and Concord, I thought was the first
one. That wasn't the first one.
Oh, there was a civil war. Oh my
God. Shaking my head. Shut up.
You fucking Wikipedia reading.
Can't nobody gives a fuck about your
war knowledge. Did you fight in it?
Well then shut up. All right. You know,
it was funny before I came in here,
right, I was watching the Celtics
lose. It's a fresh loss at, um,
I'm, I'm taping this, uh, Sunday
night, uh, Celtics lost to,
uh, the giant Jamie Fox
and the Chicago Bulls.
Dude,
that Butler guy looks like Jamie Fox
circur like around somewhere in the 90s in
living color and uh, you
know, fucking brutal game,
brutal game, brutal game.
But it was also, you know,
with Isaiah losing his sister and
stuff, it was kind of like, uh, the,
the drama of the game was definitely
just looked at us just a fucking game.
Look what this guy's going through,
but the balls as much as
they're an eight seat, you know,
let's go a little sports morning, talk
radio today. You don't leave Chicago.
Paul's is much easier in AC.
Do you have a lot of veteran
presence ed in your experience?
Uh, where would you Dwayne
Wayne [inaudible] Rondo and
yeah, it's not going
to be an easy one. Um,
and then they got that
unit bomber guy like,
I dunno what the fuck that guy's
deal is. You know what I mean?
I think when I look at that guy,
his do the hairdo he has
in the fucking facial hair.
Okay.
I just hear his agent, you
know, going like, dude,
we've tried everything to get you
a lucrative advertising contracts.
We got nothing. So, you know,
why don't you just be the crazy
fucking hair and bearded face guy.
Why don't we try that? Did the
bird man retire yet? You know,
I used to get claustrophobic looking
at that guy's fucking tattoos.
They just kept going higher and higher.
Like the little here with choking them.
I'm very colorful. Very
marvel comic. Um, yeah.
So we lost whatever man. Fucking one
game. You know, what are you gonna do?
I mean, we live and die, but we've got
one guy, we got fucking Isaiah Thomas.
That's our guy. Okay. He's the fucking
guy. We live and die by the threes.
We don't get fucking offensive boards.
End Up dying. Get Away with that in
the regular season. Come play off time.
You know, you weren't getting
both. That's what I'm worried
about. And the Bruins blow it.
Hmm?
You blow it. We fucking
blew game. We blew it.
We fucking blew it a game too.
I think we forgot that there was a
third period grown press with ourselves.
You know,
we scored three goals in the second
period or something like that or to
something. We were up three, eight
we have three to one up three to one.
Everything's going good.
And the crosschecking cons
that are the Ottawa Senators,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
If one auto was senator Finn bitched
about the refereeing in that game,
I saw one play like this fucking
guy crosschecked the same guy twice,
right in front of the net.
The guy went down twice call.
It was like every fucking third
crosscheck that that they would call.
And then that that color
commentator was so pro auto.
It was fucking ridiculous that that first
one they was trying to say that the,
you know, the goal was off sides. It's
like kind of fuck. Can you tell that?
He definitely seems like he moves his leg,
but there's no way you can see
from that shitty angle from nine.
I love the NHL too. It's
like they're going to,
they're going to implement fucking replay,
but then for whatever reason they're
gonna have a camera on top of the Goddamn
arena. Elise, that's the
feed we got. It's like,
how the fuck can you tell what the
guys on site or not? I don't know.
Might've been a good call.
Might've been a bad call.
I had no idea what the color
comedy was, was convinced.
Oh cool.
Well that the doubt that they should
that the teacher to call that one back.
Oh fuck.
You just go skate down the Goddamn
river and go get your fucking whatever.
Whatever the fuck you guys eat
up there. Um, so when it was,
we'll see how that one goes. Um,
okay.
I'm hoping I both basically opened
the same thing for the Bruins and the
Celtics. I know we're not winning the
championship and either fucking league.
I'm just hoping we can go
as far as we can. All right.
Get some good playoff
experience and build on that.
That's what the fuck I'm looking for.
That's it. That's all. Nothing crazy.
You know, I didn't even look to
see if a, I know the predators,
they won that first game. One
to nothing. A pitcher's duel.
See, you see what the fuck
happened with them and game two,
I ain't know the fucking ranges and
the fucking Canadians we're playing.
What have we got here? What's going
on? What's going on in the world?
The NHL fucking penguins.
They're the team that beat man.
Fuck the capitals till
the capitols do something.
Yeah.
Ah, the fucking Canadians want again.
Gotta hate those fucking bastards.
Then I could have went shit though.
Blues take a three game than none.
Series over the wild.
What else do we got here?
What's going on with
the fuck? Come on man.
Can you just give me the
fucking scores here? Yeah. Oh,
Pittsburgh wins in overtime.
Okay.
All right. Well where's the rest of
the, where's the rest of the scores?
What happened yesterday? Chicago win.
Should, should it be this difficult?
Should you just go on the website and
it's just all right there for mouth
breathing morons like me is, is this
asking too much? I went the wrong way.
Nashville one five to nothing. Oh my God.
Okay.
Anaheim's up two games to not Nashville's
up two games to none. Toronto, B,
Washington and overtime. Oh, no wonder
I didn't hear from fucking Josh.
Adam Meyers. We lost in overtime.
All right, let's fuck this page.
I don't want to go back
and relive this shit.
So, um, yeah, that's what I did today.
That's what I've been doing this weekend,
hanging out with my daughter
and I'm just watching playoffs.
I watched that fucking F1 race in
whatever the hell that one was at actually
taped at this time at a
great time watching that and
the Ferrari's when again,
when again, what's his face? One,
I didn't write down his name.
One of those v guys wanted, you know,
Hamilton got fucking penalize
five seconds for driving too slow,
slowing up Ricardo. And then people
would go in like, Hey, you know what?
I don't think he should have been. Uh,
I don't think he should've been
penalize for a, for fucking,
basically what was happening was Mercedes
was pitting both their cars at the
same fucking time, you know,
so the other guys in there,
the guy was not Nico Rosberg,
he's in there, that bolt to guy.
Right. And he's fucking
sitting there. It's basically,
it's like when the jet pulls
into the airport, you know,
and the in you're all excited,
you're 20 minutes fucking early.
But then the guy gets a catch me CUNA,
she could see we arrived
about 11 minutes early. Uh,
fortunately our gate is still occupied so,
well he doesn't make a difference.
We get here early or not.
We're still gonna pull up to the, uh,
the jet way at the same time. So wow.
Just sit back gladly as well.
Information that I'm going to wear.
What'd you do? Enjoy the a tarmac,
right? Same fucking thing. Okay.
So he's fucking guy. Sorry
that went on way too long.
I was just trying to remember the
names of the airport shit. Right.
So there's the other guys for
already sitting there. All right.
That Boutros Boutros poly guys
already fucking sitting there.
So he's pulling into the pits.
He knows he can't go there.
So he starts slowing the fuck down, you
know, causing the other fucking guy.
Ricardo is spots open. It's like, dude,
get the fuck out of the way. You know,
we set the way the official site, but I,
I actually agree with the officials
cause Lewis Hamilton is, uh, is, is I,
you know, I haven't watched
him much, but I think he's,
he's like that level competitive or he
will pull like a little cunty moves like
that. And I think that that's why you
get penalized, you know, cause you know,
it's like, it's like when Marshawn
got busted with the fucking, you know,
the stick to the boss,
you know what I mean?
You're going to get suspended because
even when we know we know the other shit
you've done, so I think Lewis Hamilton
gets the same fucking treatment. Anyways,
congratulations to Sebastian federal and
the Ferrari team. This has been great.
Three races, Ferrari wins. One
Mercedes wins the other. Now for Ryan,
once the third one I like, it's
gonna be a nice back and forth.
Sebastian Vettel leads fucking Lewis
Hamilton by seven championship points.
68 to 61. Tony, you guys get
into it. It's like 57 laps.
It's a great fucking time, judge.
Go see what the Illuminati
does with their money.
It's up to phenomenal goddamn sport.
It's already way better than last year
where it was just fucking the Mercedes.
It was a race to the first turn and then
that was it. It was over, but very, uh,
very happy with it this
year. Um, so anyways, um,
what else did I do this weekend? I've
been working out like a fucking maniac.
Um, actually get on the
scale. Set One 74, you know,
I got some acting work this week. I'd
like to be about a buck 72, you know,
that's the weight I kind
of need to be around.
So I don't look like a big
headed fucking jackass, you know?
Shout out to all you actresses out there
who think only women deal with that.
It's so hard is the love and it shut up.
Shut up. You're in a movie,
shut up. That's like, you know,
I gotta I can't be too loud.
My daughter's sleeping,
but my wife was watching that,
keeping up with the Kardashians and
they were having a tough moment in their
family, you know, and they were all
sitting there just, you know, you know,
I just, it just seems like
it's one thing after another.
And I know a lot of families deal with
that, but just, it's been really fucking,
it's been really hard. And
as they're saying this,
they're sitting in a private jet being
filmed for a television show on their way
to New York City
and they're all sitting there with these
sad pound puppy looks on their faces.
I don't give a fuck if I
was going to my own funeral.
If I was on a private jet
to fucking New York City,
I would be getting shit faced. The
pilots would love me, you know,
I wouldn't have a disrupt what they're
doing up there. I would be like,
I'm fucking temperate. You guys. Right.
Okay.
She sitting there all sad.
It's just hard because you know with
everything that happened last year to then
come into this year and have
more hard things to be happening,
it's just really hard.
Okay.
I would love to take that clip, you know,
and show it to people who
actually really have problems.
Dual reaction video, you know,
whoever's sewed together,
they're fucking close
and I'm guilty of it too.
Everything I've fucking
wears made in a sweatshop.
I actually tried one time there was a,
there was a website called no sweat.
I don't know if it still exists
and they made all these clothes.
None of it was sweatshop labor,
and I looked at all the clothes and none
of it was cool clothes, and I was like,
wow, I want to do the right
thing, but I can't wear that shit.
All my friends are
going to make fun of me.
So I put my own insecurity ahead of
fucking people working for sweatshop labor
prices. I don't know. I just know
it's just really hard sometimes.
Even if you are in a private
chat on your way to New York City
drinking champagne, they
weren't even drinking champagne.
They were just sitting
there and looking sad.
They're big fucking brown Kardashian
eyes. You know what they look like?
One of those fucking
creepy paintings, you know,
they make the kids remember that that
artist that just had those giant fucking
eyes that was like his thing. They had
giant, these giant fucking creepy eyes.
I gotta look this shit up, dude. This guy,
this guy actually made a ton of money.
They were considered cute in like the
70s and I always fucking hated them.
Always hated him. Oh by the way,
if you're wondering how the point
system works in F1, you get 25 points.
If you come in first and you get points
the way down to 10th place, it goes 25,
like 15, 12, 10, eight six four two
one. I believe that's how it goes all.
And then everybody else can go
fuck themselves. By the way.
How funny was it in that guy drive him
for the Honda's just bitching over the
radio, but what a piece of shit his car
was. He sounded like me in high school,
except if he's driving a
fucking formula one race car.
He said this is the most under powered
race car I've ever driven in my life.
They're all sitting like
guy, dude, not on the radio.
And then they're cut into his car and
it says Honda on the side of it. Um,
anyways, uh, yeah,
it was a really fascinating race because
there was somewhere in the Middle East
and it was, they were worried
about sand blowing onto the track,
which could chew up the tires and
obviously fucked with the traction. Um,
I don't know. The more I get
into it, the more I like it.
What the fuck was I looking
at? Okay, creepy big.
I kids paintings
seventies this is always search
for shit. I better get it.
I've to get it. Come on.
The big guide children, the
extraordinary story of an epic art fraud.
No, that's not them.
What does every art gallery have that
older white woman with a really short
hair, like a boy's haircut,
but it's like stylized.
You know like she sings in
oasis or some shit vintage.
Oh, there it is. Is this it? Nah,
that's not them. I guess everybody does.
The big guide thing.
What the f? The big eyes.
What the fuck was that thing
call wasn't called like love is.
That's not a wow. A lot of people are
with the big eyed kids. A big guide.
Kids in fucking big eyed kid.
Love is dot.dot. Big Eyes.
Let's see if that works.
All right. I give up.
I fucking give up now. Show
me a picture of spongebob.
Squarepants freaking out on some drugs.
Do you guys know the ones I was
talking about? They had little bodies.
They had giant heads ne
these big fucking eyes,
these little pink fucking
arms and shit. They just were,
they were creepy as shit and everybody
thought they was so goddamn cube.
I was a dumb kid though. Do you know what?
Every time I walked into a Photoshop
back then and they'd have picture frames
and then they will already
have like a picture in it.
Like I thought that you
buy in that picture.
And My mother one time was looking
at picture frames. I was like,
why would you want that one? I mean, whose
kids are those? And she just laughed.
She's laughed when she goes, no,
you take it out and then you put your
picture in there. I was like, go,
now that I have a kid, I can't imagine
like that's gotta be a terrifying moment.
Like, oh my God, is my kid gonna be
homeless? I'll fucking, you know,
he'd come home, you look at you like
dead, dead. Dumbness was not in me.
You know, you come home and you look at
your spouse, that's you. You did that.
That's your strand.
A fucking DNA messing up
my 50% thank you very much.
I'm all right. Let me read a little bit
of advertising here for the week. Um,
that's going to drive me nuts. It was
a big, I'd fucking kids. All Right,
wink. When you have a great glass of wine,
it enhances the moment. Yeah.
It's called getting shit faced.
Whether you're reflecting on the
day or with someone you love,
wink understands this. It's why woo.
They started their company to give you
access to exceptional wines from around
the world. So you have
more of those moments.
I just pictured them smash cutting two
people's shit face yelling at their kids.
I said, God,
just go to try Winc winz.com spelled
t r y w inc com whiskey India,
November charlie.com.
Take a brief palate profile quiz and wink.
We'll recommend distinct and interesting
wines actually customized to your
pallet to be shipped directly
to your door every month.
Why do people who drink wine
think they're so fucking smart,
customized for your palate? You get in
shit face. You're drinking like a pirate.
Um, none of your time
is wasted fitting in,
fitting in a run to the store or on your
way home from work or on your way to
invent or a gathering.
No more time spent guessing what you
might like because wink basis the wines
they send you on your taste preferences,
Winkle even introduce you to new rare
and custom wines that are not available
anywhere else and tell you
the story behind each one.
Is this doing in this one?
It's not approved by the FDA in
somebody made in the sink. All right,
but it gave, we'll get you fucking
shit. Join for free. Skip any month,
cancel any time and they have a a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee so you
never pay for a bottle you don't like.
And right now Winc is offering
listeners $20 off your first order.
When you go to try winc.com/ [inaudible]
they'll even cover the cost of shipping
as try wink,
spelled t r y w I n c.com/bird to
get $20 off your first order now plus
complimentary shipping. Try. That's try
winc.com/bar now you realize the loophole
in there is that if you're not 100%
satisfied, you never have to
pay for a bottle you don't like.
So what you do is you order
like 10 bottles. Okay?
You take a glass from each one and
be like, yeah, I didn't like that.
Then like that one and get to the
10th one. Yeah. All these bottles.
SAP gimme temore. All right.
I am not 100% satisfied.
All right. Me On undies.
Oh, too. To me undies.
Mandy's drinking your fucking wine
to do two to me. Andes me on these.
It's nice and soft on your
behind. When you drink wine,
you Satya con you take
your smart. No you're not.
I couldn't think of anything that fucking
rhymed because I'm a fucking moron.
Yeah, with velvet ball stuff.
Um, velvet ball stuff, stuff,
velvet stuff up against
my balls. Me On ds.
Everybody elevate your underwear
game to the next level with me on Ds,
you've perfected your wardrobe.
But what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been
suddenly for store bought underwear,
five packs. I have something that
will change your life for the better.
Better me on days.
What's the first thing you put on
in the last thing you take off?
Huh? That's right. Do your underwear
make your most important piece of
clothing? The best it can be with me.
Andy's sometimes it's your tee
shirt though, right? You know,
you just fucking grabbed you
sweat pants and your undies.
You just take them off and you
stand in there with tee shirt.
You know when you fucking socks
on, you get the shower going.
Your wife walks in, she starts
laughing at you. You know,
do you never did that follow
up? What is me undies?
Oh Geez. Seriously soft. Feel good undies
delivered right to your fucking right
DOR. I want to meet that
guy. What do you do? I die.
I bring a, I deliver
underwear to men. You know
stories I got along with people. It
takes a special personality. Oh, shut up.
Bill meanders are designed in La and
our was that Los Angeles, Louisiana.
We don't know. Inmate from sustainably
sourced. Micro Modal, modal of fabric,
three times softer than cotton.
Meander is softer than soft luxury.
Andy's coming in ever changing
selection of classic colors,
bold shades, bold shades,
right around the shaft at your Dick and
adventurous patterns so you can tailor
your undies to your own personal style.
You want a giraffe next to you and
nuts about a sunflower. Guess what?
This is what they do.
You can save time and money each month
with a monthly subscription and if you're
not ready for a subscription,
that's okay. You can still save.
That's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar
and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear
drawer. You deserve it. A throw out.
Those shits. They those
skid macked undies, Huh?
Once again,
that's me on these.com/burn
me undies.com/burn how
many more of these fucking
things? I got to read two more.
You want me to read these two now you
want to hear the story about me trying to
make fucking dumplings?
Let's talk about that. Hey,
where any any fucking guns
out there? Any Asians?
Listen to this podcast.
Anybody from the Far
East migrated over here?
Maybe a second generation or maybe your
family's like old school and then kept
the tradition going so you know
how to make fucking dumplings. I,
I love dumplings. All right.
I'm like Oprah right now.
I love dark lanes. I
fucking love dumplings.
And I told you the story of when I was
in Singapore and I was on my way to Hong
Kong and I was in the fucking airport
lounge and that count ate all the fucking
dumplings. I swear to God,
I don't know how his belly
wasn't hanging over his pants.
He says little skinny motherfucker
was like as a competitive eater,
they kept bringing them out in like in
like groups of like 14 and this fucking
guy would eat like 11 of them.
It's like he was flying around the world
and it was going to be no food in the
God damn plane. So the best dumplings
I ever fucking had. I was in Hong Kong.
I went to some dim, some shit. Oh,
I don't know what the hell it was,
but it is a fucking art form over there.
But I'll tell you, here in America,
they, they still do a great job,
but the dumplings, the pots,
I love him. All right. I told you
guys a while ago, I was, you know,
I wanted to get outside my palette and
I never cooked with any of the Asian
Shit, even though I love it. Right?
So I decided that I'm going to try and
make these fucking dumplings, right.
So of course I don't have any of the
ingredients I need other than the flour,
hot water, sugar, salt. What
the fuck else did I have?
And of course they had some of that
with us. Soy Sauce. I had that.
But everything else I didn't
have, I didn't have anything else.
So I go to the white grocery store, right?
I go to their little Asian section
that's right next to the Mexican section
that's a little bit bigger.
And then everything else is just for
northern Europeans. I mean that's,
that's a white grocery store. That's what
it's like. Okay. So he say to the guy,
you got any of these fucking chili sauce?
Do you have any of the dark soy sauce?
And you know,
I actually asked an agent dude that worked
at the fish counter and he was like,
Nah man, they don't have that
shit here. And I was like,
do you know where I can get it?
And he was like, no, I mean,
I don't know where you live. And
I was like, all right, sorry.
So I ended up going to a a,
whatever was a Korea town titan,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
I went and I went to into this grocery
store and I come walk in whole new
fucking world, all these fucking noodles,
all of this shit I'm looking at going,
that's the stuff when I ordered,
there it is right there. Right.
So I'm looking for my stuff.
I needed like corn flour
and they didn't have any. So when
I went to the Thai grocery store,
I was looking for it.
And there was this Asian lady there
with their mother and she sees me,
the fucking white dude around.
I hear looking at the shit trying to
figure stuff out. She starts laughing,
she goes, what are you trying to make?
And then I laughed. They sent them,
I try to make dumplings. She goes,
all right, what do you need? I said,
I'm trying to find corn flour. And she
goes, Oh, you know, it's just, you know,
since she talks to her mother, I'll
get outta there fucking, you know,
this is the real deal. Shit, you know,
bilingual shit going down and they're
trying to help me find the corn.
They couldn't. So I,
they found this other shit and that
was close to it and we were like, ah,
I don't know if we can use
that. So I was like, fuck it.
Maybe I've got to go to
Chinatown. I have no fucking idea.
So I thank them and they
say good luck and I leave.
Then I'm standing up at the
register and was hilarious.
That same woman came up to me
and this is what she says to me.
This is like a minute later she
goes, excuse me? She goes, well, you,
the guy was just talking to and
immediately I'm like, oh my God,
we all look alike him.
Okay,
so I laugh, but I go, yeah. And
she goes, I just googled it.
You can use this as a substitute. She
took the time out to Google. I was like,
you know what, you, you're awesome. She
said, no worries. I said, all right,
see you late. So now I got a new
grocery store to go to. So I come home.
So I go to the meat store,
I get my fucking pork and all that
shit and get my ginger, right.
All this shit that I'm going to put in
there. So I go to make this, make it.
The filling was fucking easy. My Bok
Choy, fucking cutting up the green onions,
all of that. It's smelling right. It's
looking right, everything's going good.
Then I go to do the fucking
dough and God damn it,
that was a motherfucker not mixing it
up. Mixing it up was easy, but like,
just trying to make them
into a round circle was a,
that was not easy. Forget about
folding them up and, uh, so whatever.
I put a little oil in the
pan. It took me forever.
It took me like two hours
to do this whole thing.
And I was talking to somebody else
who married into an Asian family.
It was just like, aw man. He goes, when
they do what they fucking, how quickly,
you know,
they can fucking get the dumpling
together and fold it up and make it look
right. It's like, it's like a
fucking, it's like magic, you know?
And I'm sitting there all clumsy trying
to get the thing together and it took me
like two hours to get the whole thing
together. And for whatever reason,
this fucking recipe I had like,
yeah.
Oh, how many did I have? I had
like fucking like 40 of them. Yeah.
Almost like I almost quit like
15 times. Just going like,
how many times could I have
ordered dumplings from the
people that invented them
that know what the fuck they're
doing? But I plowed ahead, right?
So we get the oil in the pan and
I just follow the thing. You know,
when they get nice and Golden
Brown, then you pour your water in,
you put the lid on them, you steam them
when the water's gone, they're done.
And, uh, I gotta tell you
they were, they were ugly.
On a scale of one to 10,
they were a strong six,
did not look good to many different
sizes. Even though the ladies on the,
on the video show me how to do it. I
still fucked that up. And, um, and then,
you know, I'm the worst. I have
to stop fucking doing this,
cause I always go to Nia. Like, was it
good? How does it taste? Is it good?
In the second she knows I want approval.
Okay.
She turns into fucking Simon Cowl. You're
just saying, oh, you know, they're,
uh, you know, it's like,
and I even said, it looks,
and I know these aren't great for first
attempt. It's, that's pretty good,
right? I like, you know, insecure
fucking guy that I am. I need a little,
just give me a little fucking feedback
comedian. That's why I like stand up.
How'd you guys like it? Ha ha ha. We
liked it. Dead silence already. Get it.
All right. How about this one now do
you like me? Do you like me again?
You know, that's how I live my life.
I live moment to fucking moment.
Not in a zen way. Just in a
completely insecure way. Right?
So she's not given it up and I go,
so we know what's, what's, what's up.
She goes, there's something a, I dunno,
the dough is just not a, you know,
she's clearly just opening them up and
just eating the middle. A lot of them
I go to, to like sticky. She goes, no,
that's not the word.
Um,
and immediately I'm just like, Oh God,
I just want to fucking just, yeah.
Oh, I'm gummy.
Is that the work? Go? Yes. Sticky gummy.
You want a thesaurus? How are
you? Say That fucking word.
So this is what happened is, you know,
I learned from the chef that you
gotta be, you know, tasting your food.
I forgot ever. I used to cook
and I wouldn't be tasting.
So I was tasting them the whole fucking
way. And the chef told me, you know,
by the time it's done,
you're not gonna want any because
you've tasted so much of it.
So I'd already had so many fucking
dumplings the time I got it,
like I was almost a little sick and I
fucking hate him and I knew that they
weren't right. But I
definitely had a good time.
I think I would quarter that recipe,
so only I only make like
fucking eight of them.
Then I couldn't have fun and
I could actually like take
my time rather than dude
was like, I swear to God, it was so
perfect that I did it during tax time.
Cause that's what it felt like. You know,
when you get all your
receipts all laid out.
I had all these little balls
of fucking flour, but um,
okay.
Oh Dude, this morning, like
I didn't even clean up.
I went downstairs and I was just like
eight dumplings and I had a fucking
scotch. I was doing so well on my
diet and next day I fucking woke up,
look like a starving child or they'd
like a distended belly, you know,
if that starving child
was an alcoholic and I'm
psych fucking,
I came upstairs and just the smell of
that fucking soy sauce and all that,
she'd have to all those dumplings
I fucking ate. And I swear to God,
I actually have a new found
respect for that son of a bitch.
They had all the dump
those dumplings in a,
in Singapore. I don't know what the
fuck that guy stomach is made out of,
but dude, you can't eat
all of that dough. So, um,
then of course eating like dad
kind of threw me off my diet,
went to this fucking great cookout
today and I, I, you know, I ate well,
but not well, if you know what I mean.
So who knows, whatever I'm doing well,
I'm doing well with the Diet. I'm still,
I'm still going in the right direction.
Okay. I've shaved off about eight pounds
off for the fucking Christmas Ham here.
Oh, Billy's going to be able to fit in
his suits in about another five pounds.
Get down like one 71 71 that's it.
Then we're trying that suit again.
You know why? Because I'm
not a quitter. Alright?
I hung in there with the dumplings,
but I'm not going to go down to that.
I'm not going, I'm not
going to be that guy.
I told you guys that I'm not going to
be the guy that goes down to the dry
cleaners and it has his
fucking suits let out.
She sitting here with the
fucking shoulders slumped.
All right? And if you're,
if you're in that right now,
if you're doing that right now,
you gotta keep one fucking suit,
okay. That you don't do that to,
and I would make it your favorite fucking
suit. The one you look the best. And
that's it. Again, if you have fat suits,
you literally wearing a fat suit like
fucking Eddie Murphy in the clumps,
except when they say cut, you know, in
the end of the day they can't remove it.
What do you, what are you doing? Get
on a fucking treadmill. All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody buying a razor.
It's a lot like buying a car except
it's yet it's way, way cheaper. Uh,
to get smooth luxury, luxury quality,
you have to pay a huge price and that
means you're paying mostly for splashy
marketing and features. You don't actually
need switched to dollar shave club.
It's this choice,
the luxury quality at an economy
price, dollar shave clubs.
Razors are amazing quality.
They've got the shave technology you
need and none of that overprice gimmicky
shit.
You don't have you seen the ad for the
raises monopolies newest raise a thing.
It's like a 24 blades swivel pivot robot
razor with the laser pointer every year
they make a tiny change of the rate,
tiny change to the razor and then try
to convince you it's totally new and you
need to spend even more forward and
then the new blades don't fit your old
fucking handle all that Steve Jobs Shit
joined dollar shave club and be done
with all of that.
There's never been a better time
to give them a shot right now.
You can get the first month of their
amazing raises for only a buck,
including free shipping. And after
that it's just a few bucks a month.
There's no longterm commitments.
Relax, no hidden fees.
You can cancel whenever you want.
Get your first month for just
aBuck@dollarshaveclub.com
slash Burg that's dollar
shave club.com/bar one more
read. Oh and it's nice and quick.
stamps.com these people get
it man. Get a nice quick copy.
I use stamps.com to send out any of my
posters anytime or myself after my shows
if I can figure it out. So can you
stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business
or just sit there and stare at the weld,
drinking your favorite
bourbon. I can mail any letter,
any package using my computer and my
printer and the mailman comes by and picks
it up. Avoid the hassle man and go to
the post office and mail everything from
postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international stamps.com will
even help you decide the best class of
mail based on your needs. No need to lease
an expensive postage meter right now.
Here we go. The big finale.
You can enjoy the stamps service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital
scale without a longterm commitment.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstampsdotcomandtobarstamps.com
never go to the post office again
unless you're one of those Weirdos that
collect stamps. All right,
let's get to some of the, uh,
some of the fucking questions
here for the week. Shall We?
Shall We? Um,
yeah,
the lovely, neat everybody is my
food here. Oh yeah, it's been here.
It's been here. What did I order again?
A salad with chicken. Cause
you're on a diet. Yes.
Everybody knows I was talking
to you about your, your,
your cold calculated
review of my dumplings.
What are you talking about? You know how
you do. Hey Sweetie, what's up buddy?
You just woke up. You that smile.
No. Oh, she's, you know what I'm,
I know I'm biased, but we got,
we got one cute ass kid. Just,
yeah, yeah. You're dumb.
You, you, you, you,
you made dumplings.
See, this is what I'm talking
about. It's so cold. Yes. You, uh,
you, you, you, you may, dumplings
tried. I mean, you know,
you made it. I don't mean
you tried. You did make it.
No, you can't eat this. This is, you
can't, you can't give it up ever.
Okay.
I become hard. This is for you.
Give it up. You know, I, I'm,
I feel like I'm very honest with you
is what it is because I respect you,
so, Ooh, you're going to turn this around.
That was a nice little flippy duty
did there, because I respect you.
I'm going to be honest with you. If I
didn't respect you, I would just be like,
oh yeah, everything you
do is amazing. Well, wait,
that didn't come out right either.
What I'm trying to say is I think
you put forth a great effort.
I'm just gonna let you keep talking your
way down this fucking well. I'm done.
I'm done. I'm done. Yeah.
Okay. Well, you know what?
I realize I respect you
too. What does that mean?
It means I'm going to start
being as honest as you are.
That's what I'm going to do. What is it
exactly that you're upset with me about?
Cause you can't just be like, you know
they're there. All right then a great,
that would be perfect. But
you have to be like, um,
there's something with the dough. And
I was just like, is it sticky you? Like
it's not too word.
Oh just let me just put two behind my
ear and I'll move on to the next fucking
meal. Then you had to finally
just be like, I'm gummy.
Is that the word? That's
what, and then he said,
or gummy means can we
like blow bubbles with it?
And I just couldn't even say
anything because if I said anything,
I would start laughing because obviously
I don't mean that you can blow bubbles
with it. I know you just,
you're a, you're a tough, you're a
tough one. You're a tough one. It's,
it's tough to get a compliment out of you.
I don't feel like dumplings are also
easy to make. You know what I mean?
It was your first try. They looked
amazing. The filling was good.
Just the dope part was dope.
That was do is definitely off.
I think I like overcooked it, I
think, I'm not sure, but I'm not,
I'm just saying you have
like, you have this dislike.
You just take out the sickle
when it's, when it's coming.
You turn to like an Olympic judge to
be like eager to be like yet. I mean,
not the best, but you know,
you'll get them on the next one.
Give me a little pat on the fucking
head. You're just like, nope,
these are not good. Have a nice evening.
I will see you in the morning. All right.
I'll take this opportunity. You won't.
I've been talking to you about
this for fucking 14 years.
Hey Buddy. Oh, can I
take a bite out of this?
Huh? Why can't you say this age forever?
These be these big, big
ball acute. We carry around.
She's got a mischievous look on her
face. You're going to be toughy tonight.
Like last night. Yeah,
I'll tell you it was a rough one, right?
Let me finish this up here so I can go
eat my cold fish or chicken or whatever.
I ordered chicken. All right.
No, I'm not in your way off the microwave.
Even annoying the shit out of people for
the last five minutes. Okay. All right.
Hey Nia, that that dress is, I mean,
it's a dress. You're, you're
wearing it and I still,
I can't even do it to you. You look
great asshole. Get out of here. Alright,
wagon, please read. Please read. Hey,
they are Billy baby white man as
the first kid. One. All right.
I heard the email you read a couple
weeks ago about the older guy who was
wondering if it was worth it to lay off
the booze and reconnect with his family.
I can tell you I wasn't
as bad as that guy,
but it made me realize I
could be a better person.
I could boozing two days
after I heard his story,
I called my brother and
I started a dialogue.
I should have started eight years ago.
I used to listen to you talk about
booze and think it was an excuse to keep
boozing, not placing the blame on
you. I'm a moron. Well, yeah, I mean,
I don't know you, so I wouldn't think
that you were trying to blame me.
I wouldn't accept the blame either. Uh,
but then I realized you don't drink all
day every day and that you have a full
career in a kid, in a wife.
I have a plumbing and
heating job and a terrier.
I still smoke weed because
it helps with my arthritis,
which is actually very severe and
prevents me from doing things.
Just picturing you're jerking off. God
Damn it. I can't, I can't sustain it.
It prevents me from doing things like
running and lifting comfortably. Uh,
the call to my brother
initiated, um, well,
I bet taken all that booze out of
your system will probably help out.
I don't think Busan is good for
your joints. I said I'll let sugar.
I don't, I don't, I always just repeat
shit that I have listened to. I'm sorry.
The call, my brother initiated
his inviting me to Easter. Nice.
The first holiday I would spend with
my family in almost nine years. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. All right, well I
don't know what you think and me four.
You did it. I don't know that
I said anything. By the way.
I wife was watching Dr Phil and
they had this fucking guy on there.
I, I, it was one of the most fucked
up things I've ever seen on TV.
This guy was basically
going on the Internet.
He was into conspiracy theory and he lost
his job and he went and got into this
meditating thing and he said he
had reached this spiritual plane,
um, of constant meditation and nobody,
and he couldn't explain
it to anybody around them,
like his wife and doctor Phil is trying
to talk to the guy and he goes and he
just kept going like, so what are you
trying, you're, you're meditating,
you're on the Internet,
you're meditating. And,
and then the guy just kept taking this
arrogant like line with him going yes.
C One once again. I mean
you'd have to read up.
I mean I can't just explain this to you.
I can send you links on to try to get to
my level basically of higher thinking.
And then Dr Phil's like,
don't talk down to me. Okay.
First of all, you don't know me.
I'm one of the most open minded people
you're ever going to meet. First of all,
who the fuck says that
about themselves? Oh,
one of the greatest people I've ever
met. Right? So long story short,
they bring in Deepak Chopra. All right,
another whore of spirituality. You know,
he's a whore of psychology
and this fucking jerk-off
comes in with these fucking
bright red sneakers on it,
sits down next to this guy and the guy's
freaking out cause he feels like he's
on the same plane as this guy.
And then he proceeds to basically
say that this guy is a banding.
His family, he picked his words carefully.
I will say that about a old fucking
Depok d to the mother fucking Chopra.
He basically picked his words carefully,
but in the end he said to Dr Phil
that he feels this guy is bipolar.
This fucking poor bastard found out that
he was bipolar on national television.
Like, Oh, and the guy fucking sits
there. Excellent. He's helping people.
Basically, you're bipolar.
You're not reaching a higher spiritual
plane as much as you are experiencing a
episode.
Um,
yeah, just doing that Judge Judy Shit
where he's talking all tough to this.
I two, two minutes into it, I was like,
this guy needs some serious
psychological help, but I don't,
I don't know shit fucking deep
pop coming out making this face.
I'm trying to think who the fuck he looks
like. I don't know what he looks like.
Liberace.
Yeah,
whatever. Whatever. Matt Chanel,
what is he? Is He Indian? Is like,
if India had a Liberace, this, this,
would they ever do the fucking Michael
Douglas, Matt Damon version of Liberace?
If they do within some Bollywood thing,
you gotta you gotta cast that guy.
Um,
and I love that he was just available
too, for, does he live out in Hollywood?
All right.
Anyways, I have no fucking idea.
I don't know any more. You know,
one of my favorite things too is
as my wife is on Instagram and I'm
Instagram a pain in the ass
because if you're not on it,
you can't look at the photos and shit and
I just can't join another social media
site.
But one of my favorite fucking things
are those people who take up pictures of
themselves and their amazing bodies after
they work out and rather than theirs
and in saying, don't I
look fucking amazing?
They actually act like they're
trying to motivate you, you know,
like reach Hashtag reach your goal.
Okay. Um,
hashtag putting that work in. Um,
I just out of, I think I've just,
I've just become an old man now and
I don't understand younger people.
I just don't understand like it did the
level of Douche chills that you would
take a picture of yourself while
you're working out, you know,
under the guys that you're trying
to motivate people, you know, like,
this isn't about me guys. This is
in my eight pack. This is about you.
I'm trying to, I try to inspire
people with my beauty [inaudible]
um,
that's why I don't believe in Christ.
When I just see moments like that,
it's just like, what is God waiting for?
When are you going to send this dude
back? Like, how bad does it have to get,
you know, in a way, I almost
blamed God at this point.
It's like you're enabling us.
How long are you gonna keep letting us
have the intelligence to advent these
devices to further disappear
up our own assholes?
As I sit in a podcast talking
to myself for a fucking hour.
Oh, Jesus. I swear to God every time
if they can make an appointment,
I just realize what a fucking
hypocrite I am. All right.
Little girl statue in Syria.
Okay.
Okay. This sounds like clickbait.
You know when you see little
girl finds a statue in Syria,
what she does next will shock you and
then you click on it and there's one photo
and 87 ads. Fuck all of those sites. Um,
alright bill for days people flooded
Facebook and praise of the little girl
statue they placed in front of
the Wall Street bull. Everybody,
mostly women and social justice
warriors went on about resisting and how
powerful the statute
was. I choose to fight.
Um, it turns out the little girl statue
was put up by a media slash marketing
company that has zero interest in
doing anything but creating a buzz for
themselves. Um, that's not,
that's not all the bullets itself was a
piece of art erected by an independent
artists. It was panned by Wall
Street and they wanted it removed.
The people kept it there. Everyone
is a sucker. Uh, whatever that means.
Kao And why 2012 I cited a source
below unless the rest of the twats on
Facebook. Thank you. Skip some words
there. Sorry for the stomach growling.
I'm also that white hat document mentoree
that went everywhere about the group
of volunteers that came to the aid of
Syrian chemical weapons victims was part
of a huge agenda to make America
mad at the Syrian regime.
International reporters are questioning
the source of those weapons.
Some think it was even, it wasn't even
the Syrian government were all fucked.
Love. You love the congrats
on the little lady. Um,
yeah, I believe all that type of
shit. I believe that type of shit. Um,
I don't know about any
of that type of stuff,
but I definitely believe that they,
they show images to make us fucking
upset about stuff. You know?
Um, seems very easy to
defeat terrorism. To me,
all you do is just embrace the electric
cars. Just make everything electric.
We stopped buying oil from those
guys. They don't have any money.
They go bankrupt and next thing you know,
they can't afford anything
but rocks were not over there.
They gradually forget about us.
They go back to arguing with one
another and we just slowly back away.
Why don't we just do that? You know
why? Because there's no money in that.
That's what I think, but
what do I know? All right.
Terrified of a threesome. Can I,
can I click on this link up here? What
is this link? This person sent me?
I don't know why. Oh, I know
why. Cause I don't have it.
I got to click on it when it's in the
email. What's in the when it's an email.
Now, how do I find where the fucking
email is? Live reads, boom. I go to that.
Click on Inbox, retrace all my steps.
Go to the contents, scroll down,
click on the link. Wait for it to open.
It is now trying to load. All right,
I'll get back to that in a minute.
In the meantime, terrified of
a threesome. Hey parentheses,
insert cheap redhead insult
here. Huge Fan love you.
Stand up andF is for family. Thank you.
I'm 20 I'm a 21 year old college student
who has a girlfriend that is bisexual
and beautiful as well. God bless you.
Woo.
God bless you sir. God bless you.
There's no way you don't believe
in God, man. God bless you.
We've talked about asking girls to join
us in bed and are finally getting ready
to have it happen.
The girl that's joining us is a girl that
the both of us have gotten with in the
past at different times.
Ah, it's just perfect.
The only problem is that I get freaked
the fuck out when I think about this
happening. Both of the women
involved are hot and experienced,
which is what scares me.
I'm not that astounding looking of
a guy, not that well endowed doubt.
As far as my dick goes and not experienced
it all could be you going to talk to
yourself on to this dude
and not experienced it all
compared to these girls.
How do I get past my fears
and relaxed enough to make,
to be into what's happening and make
sure I make it worthwhile for both these
ladies. Thanks. And Go
fuck yourself. Uh, dude.
Okay.
Do not fuck this up. Okay.
The only way you can fuck
this up is to not show up.
To show up and let nature take over.
Okay. It's all right to be freaked out.
You're 21 years old. You've got
two fucking smoking hot chicks,
one of fucking bang at the same time.
That's a lot. That's Rockstar Shit.
I don't know what you do for a living,
but I'm guessing you're not a fucking
rock star. So, yeah, this is a, this is,
this is fucking great. This is a
great God damn thing. Um, you know,
and if you want to, I'd just tell
you girlfriend, just be like, yeah,
I'm excited. Animal. I'm, I've gotta
be launched. I'm a little nervous.
You guys are both so, but just keep
paying about, cause it's so beautiful now.
Things should be, don't wear your lax.
Just follow my lead. Just do that.
Just be open and honest about it.
But don't take it to the
fucking point that you like.
Don't say all that other shit. You
know, I'm not vegetable. Good guy.
I could have had a bigger dick
than she's going to think,
well what the fuck am I doing this with
you for? Don't go that far. All right.
Here's the thing, dude. You
definitely good looking enough.
You definitely got a big enough dick.
Oh, none of this shit would be happening.
Right? Okay. You got
called up to the show.
Okay.
Okay. Can you get up to the plate
and swing out of your fucking cleats?
I would let them start. Let them start.
And then you just kind of fucking,
you know, work your way up. That's all.
Just start making out with both of
them. That's it. Get some fucking,
I don't know. I don't just,
just please, please do,
please for the someday 48 year old
you who probably be doing a podcast by
himself. Okay? Please
don't fuck this up. Okay?
Don't do not talk yourself out of
this. You getting in your fucking head.
All right? You've already
gotten with both of them.
She obviously likes you dick.
She's coming back from war.
You go friends still there. This is
just like, this is something else, dude.
And this is a great experience for you
to push past all that fucking low self
esteem. All right, so man, the
fuck up. Have a great time.
Follow up email please. Alright.
My girl loves me too much. Aw.
But I can't love myself at all.
All right. Hey Billy Moose knuckle.
I always forget what that is.
I know what a camel toe is.
I don't know what a moose knuckle is. A,
I'm a 22 is that a Canadian
cameltoe I don't know.
I'm a 22 year old college student and
I've been with my girlfriend for about a
year now. Things have been great.
Only problem is that she's got the
tendency to tell me, I love you,
or you're so important to me,
or I adore you at least 15 times a
day without any lead up. Oh yeah,
that's creepy. She just does
it out of the blue. I guess.
It's nice to hear,
but after a point it makes me wonder
if she has some underlying issue.
I'm the first boyfriend and she still
shocked even after dating for a year that
someone finds her attractive.
Sorry. Hiccups are coming.
I'm on top of all this. She gets
weird and passive aggressive.
When I suggest I have a night
to myself saying things like,
I guess I'll stay home alone or I'll
just eat leftover soup and watch the food
network. This shit kills me and
I usually cave and come over.
I'm an introverted heart and need my time
alone to recharge and study or read my
favorite books when we're
together. We mostly watch movies,
talk about school or fuck, which is fine,
but I need to be alone once in a while.
I have too much empathy
and I'm a pushover,
which doesn't help anything and it
doesn't help anything. I need some advice.
Do you think she has an attachment
problem or is it something else?
Thanks and go fuck yourself. I
would just work on your end of it.
Whatever her issue is. It might come
to a head when you just say, listen,
I just need alone time sometimes you know,
and let her pout and do whatever the fuck
she wants to do and eventually she'll
accept that about you.
Or she'll tell you why she's too insecure
to not spend the night and you know,
spend a night alone or she'll flip
the fuck out and you'll be like,
wow, I'm not with the right
person, but I can tell you this,
I'm not doing what you want to do in
a relationship is the quickest way to
poison the water. Okay.
And I don't mean just going
out and fucking around and
doing all shit like that.
But I mean like, you know, if
you don't like going to Brunch,
you have to tell him you don't
like going to brunch now.
You still have to go to some brunches,
but you're not going to be going
to them all the time. All right?
To not tell her that you're an introvert
at heart and you need your time alone
to recharge and study and all that
type of shit. Read your favorite books.
You know,
she has to respect that about you and
you gotta respect that about you. Okay.
Stop giving into what the
fuck she wants. Um, what you,
you having a night alone every once
in awhile is not a crazy request.
Okay. And um, I would do that
first and see how she reacts.
And you might get to the
bottom of why she has to say,
I love you and I adore you and all of
that shit 50 times a fucking day probably.
Cause you're, she's probably terrified
that it's not going to end well.
You know, she's, if she's
never had another boyfriend,
I'm guessing she's around your age.
Maybe that gave her some sort of complex,
I don't fucking know. This
is some few guys to work out,
but I gotta tell you this right
now. If you need a long time,
you gotta tell her that or else you're
going to end up presenting her and the
whole relationship is going to gradually
start. It's fucking downward spiral.
And, um, that's it. And it crashes and
Burns, right. And fucking corn field.
Okay. That's it. That's the
podcast, uh, for this week. Um,
is that everything that I wanted to talk
about, I got Boise, Idaho coming up,
uh, this weekend. Yes.
Next weekend I'll be out there with
Rosebowl tailgate legend and puck off host
all things, comedy network
podcasts, or, uh, Joe part. Nick.
We're going to have a great time
when were up there. Um, that is all.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday.